calor intenso en españa en algunos
lugares del país ha superado los 40
grados centígrados los trabajadores en
las calles de madrid tratan de continuar
con sus labores a pesar de las altas
temperaturas fatal hija esto agobiante
vamos a ver a ver qué tal
durante este mes de mayo la temperatura
promedio de algunas ciudades fue entre 7
y 16 grados centígrados más altas que el
promedio habitual para esta época del
año mayo siempre ha sido o fresquito más
fresquito pero este le he visto que ha
ido de tirón al verano pero bueno hay
que seguir adelante
los madrileños tratan de resguardarse
del calor bajo sombra y tomando bebidas
frías la agencia estatal de metereología
para el tiempo y el clima les alertaba
de las altas temperaturas para la semana
del 16 al 22 de mayo con riesgos altos
de incendios en 10 regiones del país
temperaturas muy elevadas para la época
del año en la mayor parte del país para
los próximos días excepto en canarias se
superarán los 35 grados en muchas zonas
y más puntualmente 40 grados en
localidades de la mitad del sur mucha
precaución con este calor tan intenso en
mayo
la agencia no cataloga como ola de calor
esas temperaturas inusuales para mayo
por no superar las máximas de julio y
agosto anunció que para el próximo lunes
y martes el calor irá descendiendo
finalizando con el fenómeno sin embargo
pronostican que posiblemente los
próximos tres meses con la entrada del
verano serán más calurosos que en años
anteriores